Hey, this is super interesting because it's
a sort of perfect blend of political propaganda,
but also of Donald Trump's fragile psychological
state.
As we all know, Donald Trump was woefully
late to the Corona virus preparedness game.
He was behind on taking it seriously.
He was behind on procuring supplies.
He was behind on shutting things down.
He's just been behind.
We had our first case on January 20th.
South Korea had their first case on January
19th.
Essentially the same day.
And yet South Korea immediately developed
a test.
Isolated people did mass testing quarantine.
People did contact tracing.
They still don't have 200 deaths from the
virus.
Meanwhile, we had over 900 deaths just yesterday.
Part of it is because Donald Trump has failed
us.
But here's the psychological part.
Donald Trump always wants to blame someone
else.
And in fact, he's been asked a number of times.
Do you take responsibility for this or that?
No, I don't take responsibility.
He has told us.
But in order to blame someone else for the
coronavirus response, he's implicitly admitting
that the response was slow or inadequate.
So yesterday, during the White House coronavirus
press briefing, a reporter asked Donald Trump
a brilliant question from a psychological
perspective.
And it's brilliant because it was it really
baited Trump into having to make a decision
on the spot.
The reporter asked, did impeachment back in
January distract you from Corona virus?
Now, I'm going to play Trump's answer for
you.
But what happens is amazing.
Again, from.
From the point of view of analyzing Trump's
psyche, Trump gets this look on his face where
it's almost like a light bulb goes off or
he says, hey, wait a second, I could blame
Democrats for this.
I could say, yeah, that's right.
The phony impeachment hoax did distract me
from Corona virus.
It's the Dems fault, except if Trump does
that, he's implicitly admitting he was distracted.
He's he's admitting by default that the response
was not what it could have been.
He can blame Democrats.
He's been given a get out of jail free card
here.
But to do that, he has to admit that he didn't
have the best response.
And ultimately, Trump does admit that he was
distracted by impeachment.
Now, whether it's true or not, we don't we
don't really know, kind of doubt it.
But Trump is calculating in real time.
Hey, wait a second.
Maybe I can say, OK, fine, maybe there is.
Bonds wasn't good, but it was because of Democrats.
Check it out today.
He's on the path to Mitch McConnell.
Yes.
He said that impeachment diverted the attention
of the governor.
Do you think that in any way this was happening
and building at the same time?
Did it divert your attention or your team's
attention or the vise president's attention?
Well, I don't like to think I did.
I think I handled it very well.
But I guess it probably did.
I mean, I got impeached.
I think, you know, I certainly devoted a little
time to thinking about it.
Right.
So but think of it.
It was a hoax.
It was a total hoax.
And when you think that I got impeached only
because they had a majority in the House,
they didn't get one.
They did get one Republican vote.
One hundred and ninety six to nothing.
Not one Republican step.
I don't think it's ever happened.
The Republicans stuck together and they stuck
together in the Senate 52 to hash.
This just brilliantly twists Trump into a
sort of pretzel.
And later he says, Well, even though I was
distracted, I don't really know that I could
have done anything differently.
He's saying, yeah, well, sort of.
I was distracted.
I was impeached and it was a hoax.
And Democrats are bad.
And it's Democrats that affected my response.
But still, my response was as good as it could
have been.
And I couldn't have done anything more quickly.
Trump's actual andthe answer is worthless
here as a factual inquiry.
But it is gold as a window into Trump's psyche,
which is the light bulb goes off and he gets
this idea, hey, wait a second, I can blame
Democrats for this.
And Trump, of course, wants to do that.
But he still has to argue that despite being
distracted by impeachment, he wasn't distracted
enough to do anything wrong on Corona virus
response.
It's incredible.
And it is quite a window into Donald Trump's
desperation to figure out how can he untwist
himself from this intractable situation where
he was slow.
The response was a joke.
His communications have been disproportionately
propaganda.
Every once in a while with some kind of action
item sprinkled in there and an excellent job
by the reporter whose name escapes me.
And I apologize.
I really should be naming him because he did
a really good job there.
A very, very interesting.
We have a very full show for you today.
I want to remind you, on April 9th, that's
next Thursday.
OK, we are doing a one day membership bomb.
I'm going to share something with you.
That is not good news.
It's April 1st.
So now we have our mark.
March numbers.
Three hundred and eighty nine people canceled
memberships in March.
OK.
That's by far the worst cancelation month
we've ever had.
And it's because of the virus.
People are having to tighten the belt.
People are canceling what is certainly discretionary
spending.
And I get that that's what we are as an independent
media show.
But we've got to do something because we want
to you know, we've lost a couple of advertisers.
The membership thing is tough.
So we want to do something to try to sort
of fight back and and really try to even this
out.
So on April 9th, 2:00 p.m. Eastern, 11:00
a.m.
Pacific, we're going to send out an e-mail
to everybody on our newsletter mailing list
with the biggest discount code of the year.
We want to try to have this one day membership
bomb to try to win back some of the support
that we knew it would eventually happen.
And it did start to happen in those last couple
weeks of March.
So please sign up for our newsletter at David
Pakman dot com.
You just put in your e-mail address.
You don't have to e-mail me.
You do it on my Web site, David Pakman dot
com.
Get on the newsletter.
Thursday, April 9th, you'll get that e-mail
from me and hopefully we can recover some
of that lost ground.